well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on Center Welcome to our
our lovely new studio here at the news
UK Mothership uh in London Bridge we've
left Ealing in West London no tears no
flowers uh and we're here where it all
happens uh so what have I missed I've
been in Los Angeles trying to learn the
palm trees with Stormy Daniels
um what I missed was this the age of
entitlement was a period of history when
the world's biggest brains began to
reject Superstition for logic and reason
we've now reached the age of entitlement
in which the world's biggest brains defy
logic and behave very unreasonably take
the children at a prestigious Girls
School part of the independent girls Day
School trust who staged a placard waving
protest against a teacher who said good
afternoon girls
that teacher was then forced to issue a
groveling apology according to the
interviews you gave to the male or
something the weekend apparently under
threat of disciplinary action
but the girls who remember are attending
a girls school objected to being called
girls well I guess some of them they
want to become Boys in which case they
should maybe be at a boys school
they're not entitled to undermine the
authority of the teachers in the school
to pursue their own social causes
and take this plus-sized influencer
no one should have to endure the
discomfort embarrassment and
discrimination that often comes with
being a plus-sized passenger trying to
navigate air travel by signing this
petition you can help us demand that
Airlines take concrete steps to make air
travel more inclusive and accommodating
for all passengers whether you're plus
size or not everybody deserves to be
treated with dignity and respect when
they fly let's work together to make
sure that the travel industry serves
everyone not just a select few
well Jaylene Cheney made Global
headlines this weekend after claiming
fat people are entitled to extra seats
on planes because they're so fat
she said all plus-sized passengers
should be provided with an extra free
seat or even two or three seats
depending on their size to accommodate
their needs and ensure their comfort
during the flight
well look uh jaylie you can have your
extra seat you can have 10 extra seats
you've got to pay for them
why should you be entitled to special
treatment raising the cost of travel for
everybody else because you're obese
maximum self-entitlement zero
self-accountability
so you've invited me to speak here and
I'm being hackled Non-Stop and I'm just
asking for an administrator
[Music]
if you want another place of ideas you
have gotten what you wanted
those are students at Stanford
University one of the top universities
in the world
where students are so high on the fumes
of their own self-importance they're not
entitled to Heckle a visiting judge
because they didn't like his politics
the scourge of Limitless entitlement
takes us down Avenues of Limitless
Insanity it means we have honest jobs we
can't fill but a generation of waste
rules you want to be paid for posting
photographs of their lunch at least of a
ludicrous race-baiting idea that every
white person should pay compensation to
every black person because of the evils
of History it means we give out medals
to kids who come last to because they
tried and the parents of those children
then demand they're awarded better
grades literally just because they're
paid to be there unfortunately the cost
of living crisis as a servant of these
people who think the world owes them a
favor but fortunately the rest of us are
also entitled to call them out for it
well joining me now is the associators
of Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire and talk
to the contributor Esther crackhead I
think I'm not sure but I think I might
have started that in my jet lagged Haze
Kevin was slightly wrong analogy I think
I said the age of entitlement twice of
course I was meant to say the Age of
Enlightenment has now become the age of
entitlement how's he got like this how
much entirely has no peers I think we
make progress because one Generation
Challenges the the one ahead of them
that's that's how it is now they don't
always get it right but I'm with those
girls in that school they challenge the
teacher she lost the classroom they
wanted they wanted the teacher to
address I mean they're at a girl in
school Kevin but one literally literally
their parents have said we want to send
our little girl to a girls school which
is called a girls school yeah and then
when a teacher has the audacity to call
them girls they go nuts and the teacher
then eventually has to leave because
they challenge the teacher the teacher
stands on her Authority and says now I'm
doing it my way if that teacher had
spoken to them had a child
look one of them wasn't identifying as a
girl I just don't see what the big
problem is
if you don't here's what the problem is
if you don't identify as a girl don't go
to a bloody girls school Esther have I
got nuts well what if what if one of
them identified as a tree would you say
hello hello I don't know
I mean before I went away I identified I
went to a girl I did it as a black
lesbian yeah your cackle went round the
world don't set her off again but this
is the problem if anyone can identifies
anything they like then this Insanity
just goes everywhere oh of course but I
think the the bigger message that's
being sent out here is that the children
are ruling the classrooms which should
never be the case and there's no point
of them going to school because part of
green school is learning discipline
respectful Authority how can you
possibly bully a teacher into
apologizing for calling you a girl I'm a
great believer in good discipline in
schools but that does not
it's to launch some kind of protest it's
how you set the rules and how you then
govern that school
you don't even you don't believe this I
do no you don't I do you don't think a
bunch of girls and a girls should have
the right to drive a teacher I'm sorry
the teacher has gone but I don't
believe the teachers handled it as well
as they she said good afternoon girls
and if it's then challenged and the kids
are explaining why they think they
shouldn't be distressed
do not see what the problem is this is
not the same as putting a biological man
who is a rapist and only aware a man can
in a Scottish prison it's not that case
and what happens
I can't do any more of that one this
just drive me too man can we at least
agree about free seats for fat flies
Esther the idea that the more obese you
get the fatter you become the more free
seats you're entitled to on a plane oh
it's ridiculous well I mean the the lady
in the video who was saying it she was
probably the size of the plane that she
wanted to fly look the reality is we've
always seen you know debates online
about whether you know if you need a
seat belt extension you should really
buy two seats because you're spilling
over and see the other person's person
seat and airplanes are designed to
basically continue like sardines right
so the idea that someone else should pay
for the fact that she's obese is quite
frankly ludicrous